le pont de l'île de ré ce n'est pas
encore fini cette affaire et pourtant
les travaux ont commencé le 26 juin
dernier le tribunal administratif a
annulé l'autorisation de le construire
fort de cette décision le commandant
cousteau est reparti en guerre contre le
projet de construction du pont et ce
matin il a fait un geste symbolique
parmi les témoins jean pellieux et yann
gicquel à paris ce matin devant le musée
d'orsay un attroupement et au milieu un
homme bien connu de commandant cousteau
qui ressemble à un ouvrier sur un
chantier il faut une autorisation
ferrer demandé la préfecture 38
abattus les données
c'était en inde et dans laquelle elle
dormait pas ici par paris
se faire petite enfance
à l'île de ré le tribunal a décidé
d'arrêter qu'on le continue d'assurer
la dérision ses larmes de cousteau
contre le pont de l'île de ré les
travaux continuent aujourd'hui il
également
le tribunal administratif a en effet
annulé l'autorisation donnée au conseil
général on a décentralisé c'est très
bien mais depuis cette décentralisation
qui n'a pas été encore digéré les
autorités locales ont abusé de leur
nouveau pouvoir
et il faut maintenant prenons les choses
allèrent 1 leur donnait des pouvoirs
mais de ses pouvoirs
nine banc au delà de la loi le conseil
général pouvoir local l'a emporté l'an
dernier sur les écologistes opposés au
tourisme de masse des habitants sont en
majorité pour aider la voiture je suis
très convaincu que cet ouvrage est
absolument nécessaire je crois que les
rétais tous les usagers en sont
parfaitement convaincus ils vont avoir
quelques inquiétudes je ne les comprends
cela va nous donner aussi quelques
travail c'est bien évident mais je suis
persuadé que nous avons iront aux
résultats que nous souhaitons le
président du conseil général assure que
le pont sera ouvert à l'heure prévue en
juillet à 88
tant qu'aucune autorité d'un posent
l'arrêt des travaux à l'entreprise c'est
lui qui a raison dans le droit public
français à l'heure actuelle et c'est
peut-être un des problèmes il n'existe
pas de possibilité donnée au juge
administratif d'enjoindre quoi que ce
soit l'administration
le juge administratif tout simplement
qu'à une décision illégale ou elle ne
l'est pas et c'est à l'administration de
tirer les conséquences ce n'est pas aux
juges de se substituer à l'année
prochaine démarche des défenseurs de
l'environnement saisir le conseil d'état
super tribunal administratif
autre possibilité poursuivre
l'administration pour voie de fait comme
un vulgaire malfrat
il ne reste plus beaucoup de temps au
rythme actuel les travaux pour retourner
la situation